maxime thibeault merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors vous êtes
à la manifestation j'aime le dire vous
soutenez donc ce mouvement qui appelle
jean meyer à la non mise en place du
pass sanitaires pensez vous que la
mobilisation puisse changer quelque
chose
[Musique]
alors je suis venu en observateur parce
que ça fait deux semaines que je fais
plein de plateaux télé pour parler du
passé ni terre et je voulais savoir qui
sont les gens qui s'opposent au pass
annie terre moi je suis opposé sur le
plan du droit se passe sanitaire parce
que je pense qu'il renverse le paradigme
d'un état de droit dans un état de droit
le principe c'est la liberté l'exception
c'est la restriction est là avec ce pass
sanitaire où tout est interdit sauf à
avoir un pas salutaire on est en train
de dériver vers un ehpad dans un état
policier où le principe devient
l'interdiction est l'exception devient
la liberté donc je suis venu ici
regardez voir toutes ces familles de
français des gens de partout qui qui
sont venus écouter des politiques qui
sont venus écouter aussi des gens de de
divers horizons c'était assez
intéressant mais je ne suis pas là en
tant que manifestants mais en tant
qu'observateur vous avez observé est
donc ce mouvement de cet après midi j'ai
m'adresser aux juristes en vous êtes
docteur en droit public on le sait que
l'obligation de la vaccination c'est
déjà en vigueur par exemple pour les
enfants pour entrer à la crèche ou à
l'école pour ce vaccin anti corrida
est-ce que c'est légal de conditionner
l'entrée de certains lieux publics à la
vaccination
abbas est complètement illégal parce que
pour l'heure nous sommes sous le cadre
légal de la loi du 31 mai 2021 et la loi
elle est très claire le pass sanitaire
ne peut s'imposer que pour les grands
rassemblements
donc la décision de monsieur estrosi sur
laquelle il est revenu était
manifestement illégal au demeurant les
technos qui cultivent d'une infraction
pénale punissable d'un an et de 45000
euros
parce que la loi était très clair seul
et le grand rassemblement peuvent
connaître un passage ni terre et les
autres lieux recevant du public ne
peuvent pas se voir imposer le pass
annie terre c'est pour ça que je me suis
opposé notamment à l'expérimentation
corse où je suis même opposés au décret
qui impose the past and i ter pour les
lieux culturels et lieux de loisirs faut
savoir que le cercle droits et libertés
le professeur de droit public paul
cassia et de nombreux entrepreneurs ont
saisi le conseil d'état d'un référé
référé dont on doit normalement avoir la
décision dans les prochaines heures dans
les prochains jours mais en toute
légalité normalement ce décret devrait
être suspendue parce qu'il est
manifestement contraire à la loi telle
qu'elle a été votée
vous savez hier quoi que vous avez
espoir que cette loi sanitaire qui
inclut donc l'extension de ce fameux
pass ne soit pas en vigueur en france
j'ai pas compris vous pouvez répéter
s'il vous plaît est-ce que vous avez
espoirs est-ce que vous estimez que
peut-être cette loi sanitaire qui inclut
l'extension de ce pass annie terre ne
soit pas en vigueur en france
moi je pense qu'il y a un gros problème
de constitutionnalité contraint quant à
étendre le pass sanitaires pour trois
raisons la première c'est qu'il ya une
vraie atteinte aux libertés du travail
faut savoir que beaucoup de salariés
vont être obligés d'avoir un pass
sanitaires à partir du 1er septembre la
deuxième set c'est une atteinte
manifestement grave à la liberté d'aller
et venir qu'à une liberté fondamentale
parce que pour prendre le train par
exemple vous allez être obligé d'avoir
un pas de sanitaires et la troisième
c'est que le pass sanitaire en réalité
on va pas se mentir c'est une obligation
maximale de fait les gens vont être
obligés de se faire vacciner parce
qu'ils vont pas aller faire un test pcr
toutes les 48 heures et là le conseil
constitutionnel peut très bien dire
qu'étant donné que cette décision que le
pass annie terre a pour finalité une
obligation de soins
cela est attentatoire au droit à
disposer de son corps cela est
attentatoire à divers libertés
fondamentales donc ce pas sanitaire doit
être censuré elle conseille tensionnelle
pour être simplement dire au législateur
fait une nouvelle loi sur l'obligation
dax inhalent et alors là on traitera
pour voir si elle est proportionnée ou
pas mais vous ne pouvez pas contourner
l'obligation dax inhalent par une
décision administrative qui est le pass
sanitaires mais après je ne suis pas
dans la peau du conseil constitutionnel
le conseil d'état dans son avis a été
très elliptique nous a pas vraiment
donné l'information et a plutôt aussi et
d'évacuer la question avec le recul des
libertés fondamentales qu'on connaît
depuis un peu plus d'un an et demi je
sais pas si le conseil constitutionnel
fera preuve de courage ou aussi il
suivra le gouvernement dans
dans cette entrave qui à mon sens c'est
liberticide et qui pour le coup est une
entrave dont beaucoup de professeurs de
droit c'est contre laquelle beaucoup de
professeurs de droit s'indigne je pense
au professeur serge slama je pense aux
professeurs me daugeron je pense même au
président de l'académie des sciences
morales et politiques monsieur delvolvé
qui ont écrit en expliquant qu'on était
vers une une dérive qui était loin de
celle d'un état libéral maxime thibault
mercier rouge rappelle que vous êtes
docteur en droit public vous êtes en
direct du rassemblement statique place
du trocadéro en tant qu'observateur
merci à vous d'avoir répondu à nos
questions